c'est le premier du département il est
ouvert depuis lundi est déjà plébiscité
le centre de vaccination du centre
hospitalier de versailles accueille les
professionnels de la santé
de plus de 50 ans pour leur administrer
le vaccin pfizer contre le coc vite 19
on a mis un pied dans la porte
entre dimanche soir et lundi on a
énormément non depuis lundi en 48 heures
on a vacciné plus de 300 personnes donc
à la fois des hospitaliers mais aussi
des professionnels de santé libéraux
c'est un dispositif qu'on a mis en place
main dans la main avec le conseil de
l'ordre de 78 l'aptahr la plateforme
territoriale d'appui avec le soutien de
la rs et qui va probablement évoluer
dans le temps en fonction des besoins en
fonction des demandes
tous les après midi de 13h30 à 16h30 une
salle de réunion fait donc office de
centre de vaccination
une dizaine de personnels de l'hôpital
médecins pharmaciens et infirmières se
chargent de la permanence et accueil
leurs confrères qu'ils soient salariés
de l'hôpital ou bien le libéro c'est un
grand jour voilà je suis très content
parce que je pense que c'est la seule
solution pour s'en sortir
le coc vie 19 et commence à durer et
et c'est pour que ça s'arrête aussi pour
que qu'on s'en débarrasse quoi tout
simplement
en plus de son centre de vaccination
propre le centre hospitalier de
versailles est chargée de la
distribution des doses de vaccins dans
tout le département
la distribution se fait pour tous les
centres publics et privés du département
au départ de notre pharmacie avec
nécessité de maintenir la chaîne du
froid durant le transport
à savoir à 4 degrés une fois sorti du
congélateur une stabilité de cinq jours
à 4 degrés depuis le début de la
campagne de vaccination le département
des yvelines compte un peu plus de 500
personnes vaccinées ehpad inclut un
chiffre qui devrait augmenter plus
rapidement avec l'ouverture prochaine
d'autres centres de vaccination sur le
territoire